♪ ♪
>> Dana: WE DID NOT GET TO
CELEBRATE YESTERDAY, SO WE ARE
TODAY.
"THE FIVE" TURNED EIGHT, TO
KICKOFF THE PARTY WE ARE LOOKING
AT THE PAST YEAR.
>> Juan: THIS IS A FOX NEWS
ALERT, AGAIN ROBERT MUELLER HAS
SUBMITTED HIS REPORT ON THE
RUSSIA INVESTIGATION TO A
TENURED GENERAL WILLIAM BARR.
>> Jesse: AND EXPLOSIVE
COLLEGE ADMISSION SCANDAL.
A >> Dana: UP FOR GRABS AS IT
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS CAST THEIR
BALLOTS AND WHAT IS SHAPING UP
TO BE A HISTORIC MIDTERM
ELECTION.
>> Greg: JUST TO SMELL IT
FACING A FELONY CHARGE CLAIMING
THAT HE WAS A VICTIM.
>> Dana: LOOKING AT A MASSIVE
FIRE ENGULFING THE NOTRE DAME
CATHEDRAL IN FRANCE.
>> Jesse: PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS
ORDERED THE FBI TO CONDUCT AN
INVESTIGATION INTO
JUDGE KAVANAUGH.
♪ ♪
[SCREAMING]
>> Jesse: LET'S GO, LET'S GO.
♪ ♪
♪♪ JINGLE BELL ♪
♪ JINGLE BELL ♪
♪ JINGLE BELL ROCK ♪♪
>> Dana: WE ARE SO EXCITED.
>> Juan: LOOK AT THE BUILDING.
>> Jesse: IT IS DEFINITELY
BUILDING.
♪♪ SHUT UP ♪
♪ ABOUT POLITICS ♪
♪ AIN'T NOTHING ABOUT A BIG PILE
OF DIRTY TRICKS ♪♪
>> Dana: AFTER PERFORMING OUR
SHOW ON -- SONG ON THE SHOW
YESTERDAY IT WAS NUMBER TWO
OVERALL.
>> Greg: I FIGURED THAT I
WOULD TRY TO BE A POND INTO
WHILE BEING BLINDFOLDED, BECAUSE
OF WHAT IT DOES.
IT IS WHEN YOU ARE BLINDFOLDED
IT ACCENTUATES ALL OF YOUR OTHER
SENSES.
>> Dana: I TRIED A NEW RECIPE
AND GOT OFF THE INTERNET AND
THEY SAID THAT IT WOULD BE LIKE
CHILI'S BAR AND GRILL.
THEY HAVE GREAT QUESO, SO I
THOUGHT I WOULD TRY IT.
>> Jesse: I'VE INJURED MYSELF.
I PUT MY FINGER ON THE STRAP.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Juan: WE CAN STEP IT UP
LIKE A JESSE WATTERS THING.
I DON'T KNOW IF IT WILL WORK.
I'M TRYING.
>> Jesse: AND TO THE REPTILE,
EVEN GOING INTO --
>> Dana: BEEP.
>> HELLO, DANA.
A >> Dana: HI, MOM.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW WHAT IT IS
TIME FOR?
♪♪ ANIMALS ARE GREAT ♪
♪ ANIMALS ARE GREAT ♪♪
THAT'S ALL THEY TALK ABOUT,
ANIMALS ARE GREAT, AND WHY NOT,
BECAUSE THEY ARE GREAT?
ARE YOU AS ANGRY AS I AM THAT
THERE ARE NO ANIMALS ARE GREAT
VIDEO TODAY?
I AM ON THE STREET, KIDS COME UP
AND SAY ANIMALS ARE GREAT AND I
SAY, GET AWAY FROM ME, KID.
>> Jesse: PERMISSION TO MAKE
AN ANALOGY, GREG?
PERMISSION TO MAKE AN ANALOGY,
GREG?
>> Greg: YES, JESSE.
>> Juan: GUESS WHAT.
GUESS WHAT.
I DON'T YOU HOLDING ME BACK.
[LAUGHTER]
♪ ♪
>> Dana: THAT IS JUST A LITTLE
BIT OF WHAT WE HAVE DONE THIS
PAST YEAR.
AND WE ACTUALLY HAVE A CAKE.
THERE WAS A CAKE AND YOU CAN
HAVE AN ANNIVERSARY WITHOUT A
CAKE.
>> Jesse: OH, THE CAKE.
>> Dana: THAT WAS PRETTY GOOD.
YOUR PERMISSION TO --
[LAUGHTER]
>> Juan: DID YOU DO THAT ON
PURPOSE?
OH, MY GOD.
>> Greg: WHAT THE HELL?
>> Juan: GREG, GREG, HAPPY
ANNIVERSARY.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jesse: YOU KNOW WHAT?
>> Juan: DON'T PICK IT UP.
IT'S ALL RIGHT.
>> Dana: WE NOW HAVE SOMETHING
FOR THE REST OF --
>> Jesse: WE HAVE TO HAVE
ANOTHER CAKE.
>> Dana: I DON'T THINK SO.
OH, MY GOD.
>> Greg: I SHOULD HAVE --
>> Dana: THAT WAS AWESOME.
[LAUGHTER]
THEY GOT IT.
>> Greg: CAN I DO SOMETHING
THAT I HAVE DONE ON EVERY
MILESTONE?
I READ THE REVIEW OF "THE FIVE"
WHEN "THE FIVE" CAME OUT.
I WILL NOT SAY THE PUBLICATION
OR THE WRITER, BUT FNC IS
APPARENTLY OUT OF NEW IDEAS, AND
I AM SURE THAT THE FUTURE
COURSE, THEY HAD MONTHS TO
PREPARE FOR THE DAY, AND THIS IS
THE BEST THAT IT COULD COME UP
WITH?
THIS IS A RARE PUBLIC
MANIFESTATION OF SCRAMBLE MODE.
I LOST THE LAST PAGE AND I
PREDICT THAT THE SHOW WILL NOT
LAST.
>> Dana: HE SAID IT WAS A
BAND-AID.
>> Greg: A BAND-AID THAT
LASTED EIGHT YEARS, YOU JERK.
>> Dana: I WAS TAKEN BY THE
CAKE THING, WHO IS GOING TO
CLEAN THAT UP?
I FEEL SO BAD FOR JOHNNY.
>> Greg: I WAS JUST ACTING.
>> Juan: YOU KNEW ABOUT THAT?
I THOUGHT SO, DID YOU SET IT UP?
>> Greg: I SAW THE ORIGINAL
CAKE.
>> Juan: FAKE CAKE.
I'M SAYING BEFORE WE GO THAT WE
SHOULD THINK THE AUDIENCE.
NOTHING LASTS FOR EIGHT YEARS --
A LONG TIME.